here he is now drew pearson one of the
new finalists for the pro football hall
of fame it was a long time coming but
finally drew you're on the brink of
getting in good morning thanks for
joining us how are you
oh i'm great i'm great thank you got me
fired up watching that video bring on
the vikings where are those guys
[Laughter]
well got me fired up too drew because i
remember it well as a ten-year-old who
wasn't rooting for the cowboys that day
who saw that play in real time and who
who commenced crying crying and bawling
and squalling into the carpet for an
hour after that game so it brings back a
lot of memories not good memories but it
brings back a lot of memories and drew i
don't know if you know this your name
comes up every time shireen's on your
name comes up because they play that
clip because she loved that moment as
much as i hated it so it all balances
out
well this let me say for you it was a
pleasure okay
thank you
yes yes but anyway i'm defined but i
play i hear about it almost every day i
hear the words hail mary almost every
day and you know everybody i think the
controversy whether i push nate right or
not uh keeps the play alive people
continue to discuss that
but you see on that play right there i'm
just going for the football and there's
no uh intentional contact uh we're
playing football out there so there
might be some contact but i'm just going
for the football in that situation and
luckily i was able to slow it up enough
with my hands and uh catch it between my
elbow and my hip and threw it over the
scoreboard because that's what all of us
ex-quarterbacks do we get any chance we
can to throw the football
and now drew i'm no expert in in proper
technique for a receiver but i would
have i would expect
football that doesn't entail putting
your hands in the lower back of the
defensive back and shoving him onto the
ground i don't know i don't know maybe
you can clear that up for me
sir mike it was a swim move you heard of
the swim move
the defensive back and in doing that
there was contact but there was no
deliberate push if i really deliberately
pushed him he really would have fell
okay
he fell with the contact and uh but you
know what
before that we had a what fourth and 16.
you know two plays before that we were
able to hit on the sideline for what 22
yards or so in the first down to keep
that drive going who do we hit that play
on
the guy who caught that pass didn't land
in bounds either i can't remember who
caught that pass but he wasn't in bounds
force out rule was in effect you knew
that you know that nate wright played in
the league 13 years he knew that rule as
well so uh if he would have let me uh
get my feet and you know i would have
done that toe dance right there on the
sideline charlie
so many times running that out route on
the sidelines in texas stadium
drew i had the great pleasure of
presenting you to to the
100-year committee and unfortunately you
didn't get in then but you are getting
in now and everybody talks about a
cowboys bias for the hall of fame voters
and i don't think we can talk about that
uh now with so many cowboys going in of
course cliff harris and jimmy johnson
were in the class of 2020 in that
centennial class but do you think at one
point there maybe was a cowboys bias you
guys didn't beat the steelers in those
super bowls maybe if you had things
would have sped up for you a little bit
but do you think there was some of that
there or was it just the fact that you
guys didn't beat the steelers in those
super bowls that that maybe put more
steelers in including len swan who you
had more catches than
yeah you know i i think they uh created
a bias you know uh by saying things like
well if you would have beat those
pittsburgh steelers in this in those two
super bowls you'd have more cowboys in
the hall of fame you know what what is
that you know uh you don't judge it by
that i don't think and then they also
say you know uh
the cowboys uh too many cowboys in the
hall of fame and that type of thing and
let's uh divide it up and you know
spread it out a little more to other
teams uh maybe so but you know those
kind of negative connotations
create the bias i guess within the room
and uh
you know we've always felt that there
was a bias and another reason we feel is
a bias against cowboys is because
there's so many deserving that aren't in
you know i understand chuck hallie was
close in this selection for the senior
uh door this time around and you know we
got so many other cowboys that are
deserving you take some of those guys
like a harvey martin
and compare his record to some of the
defensive ends uh in the hall of fame
and it's very comparable if not better
not saying those guys aren't hall of
famers but if they are then harvey
martin is too but there's other guys
even clint murchison look what his track
record is as a contributor and uh you
know he continues to not get in so there
might be a bias because there's so many
of us
that could be eligible for that type of
uh type that type of honor
well one guy who was a no-brainer to get
in was your head coach one of the
towering figures in nfl history tom
landry just
he just he exuded professionalism he
exuded ability and it's amazing how long
he held that job give us your best story
from your years playing for tom landry
well i got a quite a few some i could
even tell on tv and get away with but uh
i don't know coach landry you know the
thing about is i come from tulsa and i
had three head coaches in four years at
tulsa so my mentorship as an adult my
adult mentorship wasn't that great but
no of a sudden i'm with the dallas
cowboys and now my adult mentorship is
tom landry and i got in his back pocket
pretty much and tried to not just be a
good football player and do what he
wanted me to do out there on the
football field but be a professional as
well uh coach landry was the ultimate
professional the way he carried himself
uh and you know you saw him on the
sideline dress he didn't look like no
football coach he looked like a ceo
uh more of a major corporation than a
football team a head coach of a football
team and so we tried to exude that and i
tried to exude that myself learning from
my mentor tom landry then you've got
other mentors around you of course like
roger staubach leroy jordan bob
bob lilly
uh bob hayes and people like that but
anyway coach landry uh we used to tell
uh he used to try to come into meetings
and tell a little joke sometime
uh to try to loosen us up but you know
it never got it never went over you know
he would tell the joke and nobody would
laugh everybody be sitting there
[Laughter]
he couldn't understand that but uh we
did throw him in the pool one time we
had a party pool party at the royal oaks
country club in dallas and we got a
little tip there and uh coach ledger got
in the mood as well and uh cliff harris
and charlie waters were true veterans at
that time i was pretty much a rookie so
i had nothing to do with it but they
decided to grab coach landry and throw
him in the pool the swimming pool
and uh to hit to our surprise he handled
it pretty well
we saw a smile on his face and
everything so you know that story has
never been out so i don't know if i
should be telling that at this point
he doesn't know how to swim okay
that's good
one of the things i pointed out in my
presentation was how many great plays
you had we always point to the hell
marrying especially here on fridays we
play it all the time but you also had
the catch from clint longley on
thanksgiving you had the the 83 yarder
against the rams i think it was a 73
playoffs and then you had the the
playoff game of course against atlanta
when when danny white pointed and and
made the falcons disappear as they said
on on nfl films well one play everyone
forgets about is the play that followed
the catch
which we consider one of the greatest
plays in nfl history but you almost
broke that play
which would have made the catch a
footnote in history because the cowboys
would have won that game and if there
was a horse collar rule i think they
brought you down by the horse caller can
you tell us about some of that play
yeah that was uh that was a big play
after they scored we were
firstly surprised that they drove on our
defense the way they did to score that
touchdown capped by the catch by the
late uh dwight clark god rest his soul
but yeah we come back and you know danny
white's quarterback and he had been in
uh in that position for a couple years i
think at that point but he was still
trying to establish himself
as the quarterback of the dallas cowboys
and he was trying to establish his own
go-to guy as opposed to using roger's
go-to guy but on the first play in that
huddle he wanted me to run an n route i
ran that end route and running that
route i was double covered by carlton
williamson and irani lot and when danny
threw the ball the ball went by them and
i saw them collide with each other and
hit me in the chest and i knew
i figured at that point if i'm double
covered this can't be nobody behind me
so i didn't expect eric wright to be
there uh behind me to make that
a desperate attempt to tackle me that he
didn't
make if i had known he was there i could
have done something to avoid that but he
grabbed me and i felt the grab and i
tried to get away but he reinforced the
grab by grabbing his shoulder pads and
he was able to yank me down and guys you
know even with my speed at that position
on the field i would have got at least
20 more yards okay to put us in the
field focus
but uh you know i'm that play is uh
talked about quite a bit sharing you
mentioned all these plays you know
exploring the touchdowns and win games
but the ones that mean more than me than
anything
are the are the third down catches to
keep drives going you know my 489
catches i averaged 16 yards of catch you
know every time i caught the ball it was
almost a first down and those were the
kind of things going over that middle
making those tough catches and they gave
me more satisfaction because those
defensive backs when you go over the
middle and make a catch like that and
they see you and they start shaking
their head
you know you got them then you know you
got them then
drew the game has changed dramatically
over the past 40 years the explosion of
passing offense the passing yardage of
the receivers with well over a thousand
yards every year that leads to our
trivia
question tell us who the last player was
to lead the league in receiving with
fewer than a thousand yards
that couldn't have been me was that me
oh yeah yeah go with your instinct it
was you 1977 870 yards that was of
course right before the game really
opened up the passing game do you ever
think about
how much
more prolific your numbers would have
been if you had played in the era where
the rules were skewed toward
passing the ball and receivers really
showing what they can do
absolutely i would think they would be a
lot better if mel blunt didn't play in
the
cut me down league good unfortunately
but yeah there's no question you know
with the with the rules and the one bump
and getting downfield uh and not only
that guys with the rule changes and that
but the quality of defensive back is
just not the same as what i played
against you know i played against hall
of famers and guys like that and you
played against those guys each and every
year you know sometimes in a 11-year
career you played against the same guys
for 11 seasons and so it made it a
little more difficult to play but if you
if i could play in uh in the league
nowadays with these rules the type of
movement and things that they do the
type of defenses that they play uh
nowadays and the lack of quality
cornerbacks in the national football
league defensive backs period in the
national football league and i don't
know why that is maybe the receivers
have gotten better and maybe it looks
that way because they're throwing the
football a lot more but you know i just
see a lack of quality as far as the
coverage of the cornerbacks and is this
i see so many things even with coach
landry's offense that i could implement
in today's game with these rules and
really have some success we had success
with the with the rules we were back in
the day but with these rules with coach
landry's offense we probably even had
more success
you know drew when i was a kid i used to
get up on my a-frame swing set and and i
would practice my play-by-play i'd pull
the little cap off so i could hear it
reverberate and it was roger stahlbach
to drew pierce and i think you guys
scored i don't know how many exactly you
scored but when i was doing the
play-by-play it was at least 500
touchdowns that you guys made
what was your favorite touchdown i don't
know if you're gonna say the hail mary
or not but did you have a favorite
touchdown in your career
yeah you mentioned it uh earlier it's
that 83 yard touchdown i cut against the
rams in my first tough game you know
that kind of established the confidence
that the team had me going forward
because the next year against the
washington redskins i caught that pass
from clinton longley they called my
number in that situation then the year
following that you know the hail mary
and all that
but that 83-yard touchdown was a
situation where you know roger
i'm in a huddle with bob hayes i'm an
undrafted free agent here's the olympic
gold medal winner bob hayes next to me
in the huddle and roger told bob hayes
to run on uh
line up on the right side to run a post
pattern he told me to run up on the left
side to run a post pattern and last
thing roger said drew i'm going to you
all the way i'm thinking bob hayes is
sitting here you're going to me making
14-5 i'm saying oh my but anyway roger
threw that around the post pattern i saw
double coverage i didn't think he was
going to throw it but he threw it and
got past eric wright and steve priest
excuse me uh eddie mcmillan and steve
priest and i caught it at the 50 and
took it in the end zone the big deal
about that guys is that it gave me
confidence that i could play
international football league because
after that game riding home with my late
brother moose
i told him i said moussa if i could stay
healthy i think i could have a career in
the nfl so making that play in that
playoff game at that time on national tv
gave me the confidence that i can do
other things and have success in the nfl
so that's the biggest play for me
well and it definitely worked drew all
signs pointing toward a gold jacket
coming up next year in a bronze bust in
canton long overdue but better late than
never and check us out every friday
morning because drew you're going to be
a fixture anytime shireen's on they find
a way to play that highlight and now we
know
he finally admitted it folks he pushed
nate wright
to finally have closure after 45 years
congratulations drew
congratulations
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports